if you are if you work from the government turn this off right now and you can you did not hear
anything i just said anyways what's a translating what what's a wikileaks
chaos non-stop chaos you're just gonna start off the episode with chaos yeah no i i feel you man
that was uh that was a whirlwind for sure this past couple weeks so yeah i'm very tired i feel
like i need a week-long nap yeah we um just for context joel and i just got back from uh la from
the live hacking event hack one did h1213 and uh we did not dun dun dun we did not release an episode
last week like we were hoping to um oops yeah we broke our streak it's a part of it's part of the
live and learn you know content creator life we you have high expectations going into something like
this and uh but yeah i mean it was really funny because leading up to it i was like hey aren't we
supposed to record the day that we fly to the event and you were like yeah about that we're gonna have
to figure something out yeah and then we're just like ah we'll just record there with everyone and
then edit it on the spot and post it the same night no never do that and then we're at the happy hour and
it's like eight o'clock at night and i walk up to you like hey so uh two drinks in you know what do you
want to record that episode and you're like uh that's a great question yeah tonight and then we
just like started grabbing hackers and yeah that i mean that worked out really well though um we did
grab we grabbed quite a few quite a few great hackers we had we had franz nogley corbin bowman
we had yeah zazzle good old good old sam curry himself um so yeah no i'm glad they all came in but
we i will i'll warn you guys um the audio it's it's not great not not listen you come for the content
not for the audio okay live podcasts are a thing all their own um and we're figuring them out but um if
you can you know get ready to adjust your your volume indicators and um we tried to edit it so
that it's mostly level but yeah there are definitely some spots that need some love so
focus on the content for this time around and uh we'll we'll try to we'll try to keep the normal
podcast audio as smooth as it normally is yes absolutely this is this is your fair warning turn
your volume down a little bit we have tried to normalize it but there are definitely going to be
some peeks uh you know these are little handheld bluetooth mics so that's just kind of the way it
is you know so uh just uh got to deal with what we got and uh hopefully you enjoy this episode because
there's a lot of really awesome stuff in there yeah there are all right cool um with that let's uh
let's cut to the episode you got anything else you want to say before we jump right in
no i think we'll already cut it all right peace enjoy the episode guys
okay so did you i mean did you already do any intro stuff or we just rolling no i just i mean we're
just rolling we're just rolling all right yeah here here's the deal everybody um we grabbed these
little not lee what are you doing man i tried to stop yes you're good man you're good um so we
grabbed these little crappy little mics and we grabbed a bunch of sick hackers from the live
packing event that we're at in la h1 21 3 20 20 20 213 213 which is the area code for la los angeles
los angeles including in case that wasn't clear i love how we have not noggly's literally like right
here like just right off the screen you know we've already had enough of him uh over the past couple
episodes um we're just gonna we're just gonna skip everything and we're just gonna talk about bugs
today um so who wants to start us off corbin i don't know what i can talk about you got it you
got a bug in your mind i mean the transit line and cable one is okay hit us with that you you blogged
about that though didn't you i wrote it i i oh god i don't want to say it i wrote a twitter thread
about it oh twitter thread or oh got a million over a million views are you serious i did yeah
wow dang naturally well tell us about that i'm gonna go tell the other guys we're actually recording
well i'll hold this what was it in a certain year there was a wikileaks document about some critical
infrastructure that the government would not want touched okay and on that on that document was a
transit planet cable called tap 14 um i can say it now because it's decommissioned but tap 14 was
owned by a company by the way if you work for the government and you have a security clearance
you just violated if you are if you work from the government turn this off right now
and you can you did not hear anything i just said anyways what's a translate what what's a wiki
leaks a wiki what a wiki what yeah wikipedia okay anyways yeah wikipedia anyways there is this bug
bounty program that was a telecommunications company that had this on their ip range so um i was
definitely not going out of scope by scanning their ip ranges but i came across a page as a web server
and on it said tap 14 and i thought it was i mean was that was that it was it all it said it was like
tap 14 and give information like this is across the atlantic ocean and like just kind of some like
and you just like googled it i mean i looked it up i'm like okay why the heck do they have a marketing
page for like a transit planet cable like who cares like i don't even know what that is i don't even
like care oh my gosh and i was like you know i'm just gonna i'm just gonna run you know like
ff against this for shits and gigs right oh my god and all of a sudden like i'm running it on this
like really short word list and there's a directory called admin oh no and then it you visit the admin
and it takes you to a login page right and so there's like asking for a username and password
i'm like well i don't have a username and password and i realized it was running like tomcat and like had
like jsp um files and so it's like posting to like login.jsp and you tell that by cookies um no you
just view source and it's real hack hat no okay well tomcat you can tell by um like the server server
header the server header that it responds with um but you view source and you look look at the form
and it's posting like a jsp file nice so i started like doing directory brute forcing or not like i'm
just like brute forcing for jsp files and you know like hoping i'll be able to just like hit a file
on there and like be able to do something unauthenticated and there's like no results
and so i started directoring uh i started brute forcing directories next and like nothing really
happens but i saw one was like 301 and so i just pasted that in my browser um and it just redirected
me to the login page but then i for some i don't even know how it happened i think it was by accident i'd
been like i kept directory brute forcing and had no success but i visited that directory again in my
browser all of a sudden i was logged in as an administrator to this crazy planet cable that's crazy
so do you think that you got like a session through like the google search or no so i think
um i don't even know this thing was like super legacy and super old but it was like okay this
directory should only be like hit by an admin i don't know if it was like jsp like some sort of
like compact caching but when i'd hit this directory a second time it would set a cookie in my browser as
an admin and was there any like user account attached to it was just like welcome no i was no i was the
admin account oh my gosh and i like i go to the user's page there's like one account there's like
there's like 30 accounts on it this transatlantic cable has like one like admin is the username share
like password with like seven people oh no yeah and so um i have this framed on my wall but this is
like my favorite slack conversation to date it's like i reported to the bug bounty program i knew
their i knew their technical program manager um that was like helping that company run the program
so i messaged him this report i'm like i told him like what what it was and he's like corbin
why are you targeting um international infrastructure critical infrastructure and then all of a sudden
like two like like a minute later he just responds with holy shit freaking and so i had that framed
on my wall um and so i reported that to the program and it like it was the most underwhelming response
i've ever gotten they said they didn't own it and it was out of scope but it had their logo and
their name on it oh no but it was one of those deals where it was like a conglomerate of sure
sure and nobody nobody owns that nobody owns it because everybody owns it right um so they fixed it
because you know nobody owns it so nobody fixed it right um somehow they knew about it from your
it was magical i don't know it just like it went away it never happened wow um but yeah that was that
was probably one of the funniest like most absurd bugs i've ever found okay so takeaways from that
brood force stuff and pay attention to the response right yeah there could be set cookies in there yeah
and those and you know and actually it actually it's pretty cool what you did because a lot of times
when you're hitting it with fluff and stuff like that you're like you're not really looking at the
response you know you're not really like in an active browsing session yeah you're not in like
burp repeater so so hit it hit it hit the you know the end point that you got from fluff put in your
browser pay attention to the cookies because there could be some good giveaways yeah there's there's
a lot of like little things like that where it's just like you it just takes a little like
intuition a little just like observance i don't know what's the word observance you heard it first
here it's a word i defined it observance yeah hacker observance be observant one get intimate
with the application two hacker observance three touch grass all right oh gosh all right thank you
corbin that was uh hacker underscore on twitter corbin you've got um you've got literally two words to
shout something out foreign mattress company that's three words oh no what he's a hacker he broke the
rules boring mattress company boring mattress company this man is making history changing sleep
mattresses mattresses that's not money laundering that's not money laundering you heard it here first
right fbi oh my gosh all right who's up next we got we got franz rosen we got sam zazzle curry
we got dr bowman in the house we got nighley nighley yeah
he's looking for a guy he's looking for a guy he has too many disorders oh it's mr curry
sam the sam sam steph curry that's not my middle name nice to meet you
we have to reintroduce me as the correct all right sam sam sam the king curry yeah
all right so sam what are you telling us about man so we did a bunch of car hacking recently and
damn straight one thing that was really annoying was like tesla is a really hard to hack right
and we got inside of a tesla and we sat down in it we're like all right is this your tesla
this is my tesla okay yeah you know he wasn't gonna flex on us this was i helped him you know
wow okay anyway so uh tesla is like pretty difficult to hack right and we hacked all these
other car companies it was really easy and we're like kind of mad because we're like
well we can't hack tesla because they're kind of harder but like we kind of sat in there for a
second we're like all right tesla's have sim cards right and the sim cards uh talk of course
yes we're curious we're like how does tesla use sim cards so we go in the browser
and i was actually with joel and we go in the browser and we see that the ip address is owned by
at&t so we're like okay so tesla buys all these sim cards from at&t
how does this work so we go to uh business.at&t.com where you can buy sim cards from at&t
and we're sitting there and i register an account and i buy a sim card so two weeks later in the mail
i get my little sim card it's little device right and i'm like looking at it and i go back to the
website and i plug it in and when i plug it in i have my burp suite open and i kind of start fuzzing
a little bit and i see this error when i'm fuzzing it and it says uh there was an error in your jasper
syntax so i'm like well what's jasper oh that's who owns the ip range yeah so we google jasper and
we realized that the entire world's telecommunication network for sim cards is ran by this company named
jasper oh my gosh so if you're verizon or at&t or bell or whoever you basically use this company
called jasper as a dashboard to manage your sim cards sam you have an uncanny ability to find
companies that run an entire industry and then pwn them well like what is that how do you do that so
the uh the failure on this part was actually at&t but really okay yeah yeah it it is a skill of mine
you know yeah the king but anyway so you take the secret that you know is disclosed in this error
message from the at&t response and you plug it into the system called jasper right and jasper again
is this dashboard to manage hundreds of millions of sim cards right oh my god and you think you know
business.at&t.com you know what am i going to have access to so you take it and you plug it in a
dashboard and you query it and you say search all sim cards and it's like results 180 million sim cards
oh my goodness so we're looking not bad at all you know we're like a god tier token or something it is so
oh my goodness using this uh key that we returned from business at at&t.com we plug it into jasper
and we can run a query to return specifically tesla sim cards and i'm reading the api documentation
which is this weird xml api and it has like track location of sim card disable sim card send sms read
sms you know nothing too bad yeah you know and then we we list the customers of business.at&t.com
through another api call you see fbi dhs nsa oh so again nothing too bad no no so we're sitting there
and we realized that through one xml api call we could basically shut down the internet for all
teslas or track all teslas and another endpoint is basically just like read all latest text messages
right okay okay okay i'm gonna pause you here yep so you get the token how do you just put it into jasper
yeah so it took uh probably two hours of reading documentation oh man the poor guy yeah he had to
read documentation for two hours before he popped this 183 million whatever it was well it's crazy
right because like jasper as a technology runs the entire world's telecom like if you look at any
country or any continent in the world yeah they run 10 you know telecommunication networks per
continent yeah it's absurd um and these systems are public on the internet you can go to uh
bell.jasperwireless.com if you want to see bells and a little enumeration you can see the rest of
them so remember sam how we said we didn't want to have to bleep out a bunch of stuff this episode
i was outside i was outside i was on the balcony i guess we're i guess we're bleeping that one out
that one's gonna have to be bleeped all right cool
probably so we don't get a lawsuit
i just feel like we just put a target on somebody's bag but whatever all right we'll figure it out
that's a crazy bug that's a crazy bug you reported okay oh yeah so like what do you what did they pay
you did they yeah did you just high fives you're like cool thanks by the way that's out of scope
well what we did is uh yeah we emailed it and reported to at&t but we realized that they probably
weren't going to respond fast enough so we reported through the tesla bug money program since we knew
they're a customer and we accessed their data and the tesla bug money team was like fantastic they
responded within like 24 hours they fixed it or they reached out to at&t who fixed it within like
48 hours wow and then that's crazy yeah tesla actually awarded like a bounty on at&t's behalf
because we were able to actually like uh you know remotely disabled any type of tesla right so
wow wow that's crazy man thanks for thanks for dropping that one dude that's a that's a crazy one
all right who wants to go after that yeah uh any any follow-ups
what would it happen to be
france france i have an xss
france the xss is like a global xss on the internet i know right come on come on france
come on come on so so so you know that that was great that was great sam
you know about the moon right oh you know about the moon all right the moon all right so you know
you know the moon and where where it's at like right now in space it wasn't always where where it's at
in the beginning no so i i wanted like you can't you can't possibly top that so
i'm just sitting here being embarrassed for like the impostor syndrome hits hard
if there's a situation where franz rosen
every day every day then
every day like you know yeah don't be worried i have it i have it every day
now i i i thought about it and thought that i would probably bring it to the angle of collaboration
because i think that's it's such a superpower to like combine brains in in into one
and i have one bug that that was oh sorry i speak so loudly yeah should i erase my voice now
just kidding
strong swedish voice
yeah the swedish voice
rip our editing
should i take it in swedish
you don't need to like sensor it you just need to actually understand it
oh okay no no so so there was a fun bug where and i think all of us have been to that point
where i found an ssrf and the ssrf was kind of boring like you couldn't really like you could
fetch you know external things but you couldn't hit any metadata you couldn't do anything and
you're like yeah it's ssrf but what the hell can i hit with this right um and it was like i believe
it was in which is the right question by the way you know like if you have an ssrf and you're
hitting external things that doesn't necessarily mean there's a problem there no exactly follow
the logic of of mr rosen here and think okay what can i hit yeah yeah and and i came to the
conclusion that like i can't really hit anything like it's it's not really internal it's it's running
on some you know probably like lambda or like a cloud function yeah exactly yeah so i couldn't
really hit anything internal um the only the only thing that was like different from but it's not
really different from many other but the only thing that was different was that the result of the ssrf was
showing up inside html so you actually got html back inside the content there was like rendering of
the data that you were fetching and the content type was html yeah inside so i mean you had like a
xss of course but that wasn't as fun and and it was like super annoying uh having that because i'm
like yeah the biggest thing you can do here is an xss and enter matthias avlid imbrunn mr matthias
carlson the one and all shout out um i i finally got him into bug bounty again and i'm super happy for
it is he's back he's back oh my god yes batman and you know you know what the first thing is when he
gets back he writes automation so wow he was he was i i believe i'm not gonna take any creds for from
anyone but i believe he and shobs played with an idea very early on pre-asset note but they the the
app that they were playing with was called asset notes so but that's the beta version of yeah exactly
i remember exactly i think they sourced it yeah at some point yeah i remember in high school i was
trying to set that up yeah there's a terrible installation notes though yeah so but but so he
went away and came back now and he's like now he's building his own monitoring again called snooper
i made now it's it's not for sale or anything but he's he's like he's done he's done it again and
the funny thing this was happening at 3 a.m in night in the night and he's like weird idea like
what if you can do like a template injection in the html from the ssrf and i'm like yeah that that
sounds crazy man he's like yeah i know whatever and we went to sleep the day after and the day after
my kids were at home and i was like you know they were busy with something and i'm like yeah i'm just
going to test that and i'm like i've never done ssti uh like what what do i do he's like yeah you can
try these three ones and the third one was like what the hell is that he was like yeah but it might be
node so this it's like with the you know presented shine and you know brackets and percentage sign and
stuff yeah uh so i try that and like i do like two times two on all of them and like went put it on my page
make the ssrf reach that one fetch it back in like four and i'm like no you're right
you're like it's evaluated he's like oh was it the third one yeah oh it's ags like egs like yeah yeah
it's just going straight to evil i'm like are you sure yeah yeah he's sure and i'm like process and
like get back object okay process not like and then i came to require it and it's like function okay
require like child process yeah object okay uh and i'm like you crazy man thought of this idea i've
i've never thought about it and i'm like how many ssrfs showing up somewhere had ssti and i never knew
about it like i'm just like i love that idea about like some crazy thought about yeah what if it just
gets passed back into the template and yeah so i love that i i think that was a beautiful what does the
code even look like for that on this like i can't even imagine like yeah yeah it's a good question
and then it's it's putting it into the template and then rendering and then rendering it yeah it's not
even a parameter or something it's like before the template is even you know put into rendering mode
it's injecting that kind of thing inside right yeah yeah it puts it in the string and then yeah
yeah wow so so and it was just beautiful that he he had the idea and i'm like yeah i'm gonna try it
tomorrow it wasn't even that serious but i love that idea of like collaborating with with those weird
thoughts because that was an a proof that sometimes those crazy ideas can actually be
happening for you and and i love that reminds me yeah yeah look at that crazy that's awesome that
reminds me of that that paypal oh yeah no you should like it okay all right all right thank you
all right if we're if we're doing template injection stuff i mean well we talked about this on a
previous one that's right you already dropped this one right yeah i i you know i keep on forgetting
you know whether we've talked about it on the pod or whether it's just chatting yeah all right we got
yeah dr anybody else want to go dr going's up all right all right hit us with some magic
i'll also i only gave corbin the shout out i totally forgot to let anyone else shout anything out so
we'll do that at the end yeah so what i love to do is creativity um and so i always try to think a little
bit out of the box and about a year ago i was involved with some program that was active in the
music industry so i thought like hey i might become a music artist myself give yourself a little hair
flip there with that there you go but yeah because i want to become an artist so i get access to certain
assets i normally don't have access to sure and one might say hey that's social engineering but well
if you actually create music if you actually create artwork if you're an artist if you're a real user of
the product yeah yeah yeah so and this is this is this is uh something that not many people have heard
but um what i did i reached out on fiverr we all know fiverr oh my god and i i got me uh myself some
lo-fi uh a guy who created a beat i um searched myself for the word bug bounty on some search engine
that indexed all the subtitles in the world of all moves and video series so i discovered that the a
team got a certain moment in their in their series where they talk about hunting bug boundaries no way
so i got that that phrase um put it also on fiverr and get a vocalist to to to uh to make a
a i can say an imitation of it yeah because i was too scared of using the original 18 part because
i thought okay my music get released i might get sued top of the charts man you know and then i had
to find someone to create yard work of course pixel art thingy allison wonderland style so this man
dropped like you know 200 on this poc like for sure actually i for this sort of stuff i spend money so
um yeah i spend on this one i think 400 or so 500 and i want that i want those people to earn good as
well since they help me and it's a risk and in the end if the book works you got a good story if it
does not work you still got a good story to share so and here we are so so this is the the artwork
cover it's wonderland that has to decide which route to go okay yeah yeah so so there's a route
with out of school maybe we'll overlay it on a favor and stuff like that and and addison wonderland is
wearing a sweater with my initial uh domain name where's my blind xss thing i might have to have you
send that to me and um then i ended up with this song and it's not being published before and it's
really hard to find it but let me put it on yeah so i've been collecting on bounty for 34 years now
this is crazy dude yeah that's sick this is my dream union no pi thing and it is really chill
i just like to imagine he's got this going in the background so i feel like you got to take this
and this is going to go at the end of the podcast yeah this might have to yeah yeah yeah perfect
and there there we go because um i released this soundtrack with all my xss payloads as artist name
as label name because i became my own label as well as i put it in every credit option that was
possible so i pressed this button on uh submitting uh or publishing or testing review something like that
and i went to bed and the next morning i woke up to i'm applying the excess reports and i thought okay
this is good but the the domain name i just hid it is a major record label and it's not actually the
third party oh and i was like hey wait a minute of course this this for party on the internet where you
can publish your music on as an independent thing is is showing the music to all the major labels so they
can discover talent but i popped one of their administration panels and i could see
all the stuff of major artists unreleased the guy's like yeah these major labels are like man this one
slaps guys like this is this is the song no but bug bounty no what what actually happened was in the local
store when my blind xss uh pops it it steals like everything also the local session storage
is called i think yeah and in that thing there was a big is that a custom payload wait is that no no
it's easy access easy access solid yeah so you can just yeah you can just find it on get up install it
but um the thing is that in this local session storage was some big g's and blob with all the the the
the music in the queue and our being reviewed not reviewed and with major artists there and i was like
okay i know now this rap artist is going to release and oh dang so so so i felt a little bit like ouch this
is this is hot stuff but i need to report this to the major record label yeah but it was a problem it was
midsummer so nobody was in the office nobody to reach out to what does this mean what it was what
nobody was there in the office it was midsummer oh okay so i'm in the summer okay wait wait we were
talking about that i saw this on discord is this a real thing like in europe that like in the middle
of the summer like nobody's like we don't work what yeah no no no it starts meanwhile in america by the
end of august people are coming back and then on the first day of september everyone is in the office
again but talking about our holidays and on the second week of september you try to work
this is ridiculous meanwhile in america we get one day a year off but imagine it's the first of august
and you just hit this major record label and the payload keeps popping so i got it all day i got
and i had to reach out to them and nobody picked up the phone and at a certain moment i finally got
someone on the phone i was like okay i want to report a security issue with your oh no this person
is not in office you can send it to katrina but katrina is not actually my well yeah our security team
is out of office for me for the summer yeah so you just come back in like three months yeah but in the
meanwhile i'll also reach out on linkedin to the ceo and and um he did not respond for two days i i got
someone to to uh help me out with linkedin premium so you can push your message a little bit more
and then i got an email back shut up stop chasing us oh no and i was like okay this is not good and
also the country where this company was uh was was headquartered is a company is in a country not not
safe for ethical hackers they're they're known for uh well easily putting lawsuits and and proceeded stuff
so i was like i got this beautiful song i want to release i popped the major record label
i need them to fix the book so my song can't get published oh there you go exactly
and well after a while the there's their computer man the the their cto came back and he reached out
to me like hey this is really cool yeah we fixed the buck can you check check again so uh yeah i checked
again i did not see any new fires so i said yeah it's it's fixed can you now uh press this approve
button so i can proceed with my research so this guy was really helpful he pressed the approve button
so it gets sent through the api back to the asset i was attacking and it popped
yeah and that was one of my best bucks in the last year with a lot of risks and a lot of
prop writing i mean we preach it all the time here on critical thinking pay pay the money get access to
the premium product develop your own song and you too one day could be right next to drake when you get
the approved button nice yeah very good that's awesome thank you dr all right now glee do you what do
you do i mean do you have did you already spill all your secrets or you got something you want to talk
about some cool bug all right but it's not funny all right that's fine you know leave that to me no but
i have some funny so small funny stories okay cool so let's say supplement takeover okay you want to
introduce me no okay so this is this is uh wow wow wow wow this is ugly thank you thank you very
much we're gonna like i'm gonna keep i i get the mic too close and then you know we all get them i
don't want to edit this so like keep it there you go like this yeah i can always amplify the sound but i
can't yes you get it you get it okay let's go okay so one funny anecdote about supplement takeovers okay
so you know i find argument takeovers occasionally we've heard yeah just kind of manually right yeah
manually manually coming back every 30 seconds and then it was like 1 a.m some friday night and
we don't work on the final night oh i think you don't work on the night as well and then i get it
weird alert for a company which is worth a couple of billion dollars and i see hey you found the takeover
on www.company.com actually on their own www domain because usually those companies they have
marketing websites at their www yeah and this company they had like a wordpress vendor that did it and then
they messed up somehow so i just see like okay it's 1 a.m and i see all these major websites that a
lot of users use and it was few billion dollars twitter at nuggly-nuggly this is like my every
automatic payload dude holy what am i doing now like it's 1 a.m everyone navigate to the website
seeing my twitter handle you know i think if it was me i don't think i would have even clicked on that
alert i would have just assumed like it was late at night i would have just assumed ah man you know
something false positive something must have popped up yeah so it was like very very interesting just
seeing my website i've got some dms on twitter so in the morning when i woke up and they fixed it like
eventually in the morning i saw some dms from the website developers like the third party company that
developed it for the client and they said what have you not on website why did you do it why did you do
it we want it back oh my gosh so it was like a very very unfortunate this poor developer went in
there it was like oh i'm just gonna like change the name on this thing for just a second and nuggly just
like sniped it out from underneath them wrecked oh my gosh
that one was really funny and and yes i have another story oh yeah okay we're getting a double
nuggly special yeah sorry for stealing the show okay and so basically last year on some one live
hacking event so usually i come to live hacking events i have to find the creep on the on side because
the competition the pressure the tense justin up on the leaderboard okay i have to put a fight so i was
with andre there was some show they taught us some new techniques and me and andre said oh let's just
like to hack the weirdest bug ever we we set ourselves a goal we want to have authentication bypass we want
to get take over an arbitrary account it's one yeah this is how a lot of crazy bugs start too let me just
say is like you set yourself a goal like i want a shell on this thing or i want auth bypass and then
you just keep on pushing and pushing and pushing until you get it yeah so basically in this case we wanted
to take over another account all we had is like email so we just created an email and then we try to take
over the other account it was like it's a public program everyone uses it it's super hard and no one like
there are almost no bugs left on this program so basically what we did we set our account as admin
at gmail.com and then we try the variation that he likes to use and i also like to use it's called
ordinal indicator a what it means is like it's a very tiny a it looks like a yeah a and it's a unicode
character yeah it's unicode but it really it really looks like a but it's super small it's called
ordinal indicator on google so what you do is we change another email another account that admin with the
speciala.gmail.com and when it let us change it when it passed it like didn't throw an error it
was a good sign at first okay we can use this character so now our mission was to get to all
the subdomains of this company check every sso implementation everything that might pass between
different services i remember this bug yeah and that we might like get authentication bypass so like
i tried 400 subdomains i think manually oh my gosh just logging in logging in logging in and then like
i think the last one almost i just signed into the account and then i said wait how did i sign in i
never registered here and it was like very weird and then i see so sso'd from the main domain yeah so
basically they had like their own sso and they said okay we know this user he's admin and then
the passing between the two applications called the like the ordinal indicator a is the normal a and
then we just got in the application 28k dollars but it was like very very crazy the most creative bug of
the event nice man and it was persistency and like okay we want the authentication bypass okay and you just
stick to it yeah okay so reviewing that you you signed up on the main site you used a unicode character
in the place of you know for admin at google.com then you put weird a demon yeah at google.com right
yeah and then when you single sign on onto a different thing normalize the unicode character
and logged you into admin at google.com yeah the actual account that we targeted dang that's fire
man it was andre's he works like to be great hackers it was like very cool bug andre's got some crazy
yeah yeah yeah and andre always have always have amazing bugs yeah oh yeah all right now we get out
of here thank you all right okay i think that's it i think that's it i think that's it what what time
we at we got 36 minutes oh it's perfect perfect perfect all right we got we got three minutes of uh
dr moment song at the end not not too not too bad for an impromptu episode
now we just have to edit it it's currently 10 45 9 45 releases in what six yeah you're lucky you
saved three hours you came to the west coast oh my gosh well you should like say a whole name
yeah okay all right hold on let me just let me just uh well actually no i'm not even gonna try to touch that
okay we got we got mr franz rosen which everyone everyone already knows franz rosen franz you got
anything you want to shout out or anything hello the best we got some really like self-serving hackers here
all right nogley nogley wants you to watch the podcast and tell your friends about it and post
on linkedin and post on linkedin he wants to post on linkedin nogley needs you to go to okay man i'm
gonna have to make linkedin for this podcast okay listen i'm not gonna check out i'm not gonna do it
now shockwave security yeah but i'm not gonna do it now but nogley wants you i'm not gonna do it tonight
mariah says i'm gonna do it tonight so i'm gonna go make a linkedin for critical thinking tonight
and nogley in honor of nogley's amazing double bug special yeah go give it a what do you even do on
linkedin you follow follow go get a follow on linkedin yeah follow on linkedin we got mr uh mr corbin
ceo corbin ceo corbin leo hacker underscore boring dot co boring the expensive domain we were
we're not just gonna disclose we got mr zazzle the king curry can we just sing curry oh oh he's taking
his stage okay before i shut this out i just want to say that ian carroll did promise me ten dollars
if i would say this it is two words but there's a there's a period in between it oh domain name all right
so imagine i say a period like dot in between seats arrow arrow as in the airlines oh i see what you're
saying seats i don't get it stop seats dot arrow go to check out seats dot arrow yep seats that arrow
seats that area okay there we go dr bowman you got a thing for us never give me a referral link for
that by the way okay if you know i want to do my mom okay listen to this hi mom i'm i'm sure you're
watching this she's she's always keeping track of the leaderboard and then sharing pictures back with me
hey i saw you oh yeah that's so sweet hi mom and then also also for you're so passionate about like
bug bounty and what you do bug bounty for so why don't you share a little bit about like what you're
passionate about in the industry oh okay all right why i'm doing this actually that's your question
yeah yeah well the thing is um by uh by day i work as a medical doctor by night uh as an ethical hacker
researchers whatever group is in front of me but um what i will trying to do is learn as much as
possible to to figure out if the stuff we use in healthcare is safe and a lot of stuff is not safe
and that's okay if we discover it soon enough then we can fix it and yeah there's still mindset there
like oh no we've got this iso thing we've got the certificate and now it's good and now we can put
this device in the human body and then say goodbye it's bluetooth the stakes get a lot higher in that
scenario you know yeah so so that's that makes me um a little bit passionate about trying to figure out
what tricks are there and and and what to do to break stuff and to show people like hey you should
fix it in my doctor work i've got a lot of bad news conversations like hey this is bad stuff happening
in your body yeah with ethical hacking you got the same hey this is bad stuff happening so there's a
lot of similarities this man is a pro at delivering bad news yeah always trying to do it with a good
soundtrack there is do that yeah yeah and my doctor work is different though yeah but um yeah that it
and i'm trying to combine both worlds um solid there's a lot of stuff we can learn from medicine
since the bug bounty world is maybe 10 20 years old uh it's young it's really young medicine is well
going on for at least 1000 years if it's not longer um and we managed to accelerate a lot in the last
100 200 years by sharing our knowledge yeah and that's what i'm trying to bring back a little bit
to to hacking like hey whatever you learn if you're able to teach others share your stories if your
company don't be afraid that people will judge you because you were hacked by an ethical hacker no
people judge you by you don't share that you were hacked exactly we got some famous password manager
that was not sharing uh honestly what what's going on and if they did from the start and they showed us
all the technical details yeah we would have learned from them and like oh whoa this is cool yeah let us
hack you again and then we might uh uh be there uh in time and not for sure too late so yeah just a little
bit of my good good good call mariah having him share that all right let's let's give him a go let's
give him a round of applause all right joel you got any got anything for us on the way out um no dude
i listen uh this event is coming up tomorrow yeah it's pretty crazy we have a bunch of cool bugs
hopefully we'll be able to talk about them at some point i hope so in the meantime we have to go edit
this so yeah peace out peace peace i've been collecting on bounty for 34 years now and i know
what i'm doing and this bug bounty is the one i've been waiting for all my life and i am to see that
everything goes just right we'll get him daddy don't you worry well we better get him hey everybody
thanks for checking out this week's episode of the critical thinking bug bounty podcast we hope you
enjoyed for more bug bounty and hacking content you can find all of our other episodes wherever you get
your podcasts if you'd like to watch our show in a video format you can also find the episodes over
on our youtube channel that's youtube.com at critical thinking podcast if you have a moment
please consider leaving us a rating or sharing this episode with your friends and colleagues
that helps a ton and it is the best way by far to directly support the podcast next week we're
going to have an amazing exciting new episode coming out all about source code review justin and i will
be talking about all the key takeaways and learnings that we had while prepping for our last life hacking
event and a whole lot more you're not going to want to miss this one see you there peace
so
you